it's here the guise of BTS dropped their
latest album love yourself answer so
Friday's canceled nothing else batteries
only they have a song with Nicki Minaj
hey yeah
BTS army where you at it's the grand
finale of the love yourself series from
the kpop sensations the repackaged album
is the last of the four-part series and
this one includes 25 tracks of BTS
goodness if you listen to it already
what do you guys think so far is it your
favorite in the series let me know
thankfully on it there are hits from
love yourself tear and seven new brand
new bops including this bigger idol
[Music]
that video is so dope and I'm already
practicing the choreography idolize it
all guys traditional Korean music EDM
trap rap and if that wasn't enough
there's another version of the song
featuring Nicki freakin Manoj bringing
together two of the biggest fans of
music the barbs and the army
[Music]
oh love yourself series started in March
2016 that's two and a half years ago
people and they're going out with a bang
RM said they wanted to just enjoy the
process on this one and hope to
celebrate with the army and answer is
the final piece of the puzzle and as I
found out all of them share one key
message loving yourself is where true
love begins actually my final goal of
the whole my whole life is to love
myself like for real because you know
it's always the hardest
we sometimes compare ourselves to others
and you know like sometimes get really
depressed or you know so but in love
like we should be we should be you know
take up the mask and be true to ours who
we are all I can say is thank you for
this weekend bop BTS speaking of it is
Friday and there are some other new jams
we need to talk about Nick Jonas dropped
his first new song since getting engaged
to Priyanka Chopra and while they
haven't picked the date yet it sounds
like Nick is ready to say I do right now
[Music]
Nik popped the question after about two
months of dating and only recently
confirmed the happy news on Instagram
but he's told me going public with his
love is something he wanted to work on I
have regrets about not being open with
relationships in the past you know
that's that's the thing that makes it
actually more challenging is on many
levels you end up trying to hide the
relationship or do things to try to keep
a private but it actually just puts more
stress on the relationship okay moving
on to Liam Payne whose new EP first time
is out now my favorite song Offutt is
this sweet and soulful home with you
[Music]
I gotta say I am still amazed by the
success each member from one direction
has had on their own outside the group
and Simon Cowell told me Louie is
working on a show with him in the UK but
he also gave us 1d fans hope for a
reunion and yes I'm Hawking another one
of my interviews what's the latest on
one direction will we ever get them back
together or they're having a lot of
success solo well that's a good question
Louie's working with me on a show at the
moment in the UK I just think the legacy
is too big not to go back to at one
point
plus they have enough songs I didn't
realize how many hits they'd had though
they that when they do get back together
it will be a huge event but look they're
all doing their intent they're all being
successful but I have a feeling of what
happened I really did yes I wanted to
happen I need it to happen I am finally
Nicki Minaj has been a busy girl because
she's also featured on Jason Derulo's
latest jam with David Guetta say hello
to goodbye
[Music]
baby
[Music]
I'm gonna say I'm sorry but this week's
new music Friday is fire you can quote
me on it you're welcome friends ok this
Friday so enough of my face but before
you guys go make sure you check out our
latest episode of our youtube series
ship really featuring the flash I'll see
you guys on Monday for another dose of
daily Dan here I go in a flash